by the way did you see what dorsey said
about brian stelter can you pull up that
tweet reliable sources no i i
don't know if you guys saw what dorsey
said about uh brian stelter so
uh so can you make that bigger so i can
read that so brian stelter says tucker
cross and always selling the same thing
uh he is selling doubt
and then jack responds a minute later
and you all are selling hope oh god
that's hilarious that's from jack wow
then everybody says [ __ ] jack is
defending tucker and he continues not
defending a thing i'm holding up a
mirror beautiful is what he says right
so think about for jack to say that to
brian stelter
i mean
jack is supposed to be
part of that camp yeah so then we all
know what happened with cnn plus let me
read some of these statistics to you
folks here's what happened with cnn plus
cnn plus will shut down april 30th just
one month after launch okay
this is a 300 million investment that
was lost warner brothers discovery has
decided to shut down cnn plus just weeks
after its launch this is not a decision
about quality we appreciate all the work
ambition and creativity that went into
building cnn plus an organization with
terrific talent and compelling
programming right
chris lake chairman and ceo of siena
worldwide said but our customers and cnn
will be best served with the same
simpler streaming choice one of media
launched a standalone
new service less than a month ago on
march 29 it garnered less than 10 000
active viewers in two weeks after its
launch the company said customers will
receive prorated refunds on subscription
thank god but 300 million dollars was
lost with the launch and they brought
chris wallace from fox imagine he
doesn't have a job right now pissed off
he has to be he was at fox for 20 years
and he left for cnn plus yeah and did
you see any of the content they had like
don lemon cooking with his mom on
facetime and the there was no wi-fi so
you couldn't even see her uh
uh who's a white hair guy anderson
cooper anderson cooper was in his
kitchen and he's like i'm gonna do this
segment but my kids sleep like it was
just horrible
kim kardashian marriage to former
basketball player chris um for 72 days
last two and a half days you messing
with me buddy this is what you're doing
yeah that's hilarious that's hilarious
did you did you did it show it like uh
does john do you have that up or no um
300 million dollars cnn plus wow lost
this don lemon first of all is there
anybody more boring than i hate is so
boring yeah have you ever tried
listening to him i
in the gym you know all the gyms in l.a
it's cnn on every dude it's it's torture
when you're running it gets me angry
because they plaster it on everything
and it's just him sitting there judging
and talking [ __ ] about everybody i hate
that guy i really hate him if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]